how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and of course the MCU
and today we have some really exciting
reports to break down reports involving
spider-man 2099 spider-man and daredevil
specifically Charlie Cox's daredevil
reports that these two could possibly be
coming to two separate shows but both of
which could be linked to the MCU we know
that Disney and Marvel Studios are
getting the rights back to Charlie Cox's
daredevil from the Netflix series from
Netflix according to marvel's contract
with Netflix they're getting the
character rights back at the end of the
year however there have been reports
that they may have actually already
gotten the rights back to daredevil and
originally everybody thought when they
heard this news that oh they're getting
the rights back because they want to use
him in spider-man 3 they want Matt
Murdock to be Peters lawyer and Charlie
Cox has actually commented on this news
so lots of very important things in
regards to the future of the MCU with
these reports and we'll break it all
down if you're new be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on the MCU and I'm
also giving away a Iron Man Funko pop
figure this week as well just subscribe
it like the video and leave a comment
down below to enter so yesterday on Star
Wars day may the fourth Mikey Sutton who
was known in the community for dropping
several leaks dropped a couple of Marvel
scoops one about a new daredevil show
and one about a new spider-man 2099 show
and yesterday to his group ki Gossett II
on Facebook Mikey posted the following
scoop for three seasons on Netflix
daredevil busted through seedy hallways
and shed blood in the gutters it was
among the MCS most critically acclaimed
and popular TV series echoing the
streetwise grit and Catholic subtext the
Frank Miller's iconic take on the
character
[Music]
with the creation of Disney Plus and the
removal of the Marvel programs on
Netflix its future has been the subject
of speculation and rumor last year in
September
Maiki reported that daredevil will
return to television in its true adult
nature and now recently Mikey was given
an update one that will excite fans who
have been desiring a closer connection
with this and the theatrical MCU Mikey
says that although legally they can't
work on the series right now at the
moment talks continue on what will be
done and fortunately for us he's heard a
little bit of information and he says
that first of all they're leaning on
bringing the series to Hulu instead of
FX the budget will be higher but not on
the level of what they're doing for
Disney Plus they would also like some of
the rougher edged MCU characters to
possibly guest on the show like Nick
Fury for instance but there's another
difference while Kevin Feige liked the
original series he's not so keen on
continuing what Netflix did and instead
incorporate his own vision however his
preference is to retain Charlie Cox as
daredevil and some of the other cast as
well as of right now
no negotiations have begun yet because
they simply aren't allowed to legally
what we're looking at is a possible soft
reboot one that is firmly set in the MCU
if Ryan Reynolds can play two different
versions of Deadpool so can Cox and
daredevil the multiverse can explain
that away if need be however there are
no plans for daredevil to join the
Avengers instead what has been brought
up is the possibility of daredevil
joining forces with Moon Knight the
Punisher and Ghost Rider among others in
the midnight sun's and the midnight sons
and Ghost Rider have been rumored a lot
recently but that's Mikey's report on
daredevil and that should be pretty
exciting the fans as fans have really
wanted a bigger connection between
Daredevil and the MCU as it was before
with the Netflix shows and even with
Marvel's agents of shield they connected
to the MCU however the MCU didn't really
connect to them the events and
storylines that happened in the MCU
affected what happened in these shows
however any event that happened in the
shows did not affect the MCU and this is
where fans were kind of disappointed
that their characters weren't truly in
the MCU and Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel
videos himself basically came out and
said yeah they're pretty much not
related to the MCU but one thing that
you absolutely have to keep in mind is
that at the time when all of these shows
were going on Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios was not in charge of
the television shows however since then
he has been named chief creative officer
CCO over Marvel in its entirety that
means that he is now in charge over
Marvel Studios he is now in charge over
Marvel Comics and now in charge over all
television shows and that includes any
Disney Plus show and any Hulu and FX
show so it's a completely different game
in ballpark now Kevin Feige can link all
of the characters in any show that he
wants to the MCU and he's already stated
that every single Marvel Disney pleasure
that comes out with the exception of
what-if is going to take place inside of
the MCU and you're going to have to
watch the Disney Plus Marvel shows in
order to keep up with the films and it
sounds like based off of my Q's report
that if they do decide to do a daredevil
Hulu show it's going to connect to the
MCU and they're going to keep Charlie
Cox which again is something that
everybody wants because everybody wants
Charlie Cox to return but now let's talk
about the new spider-man 2099 news this
again comes from Mikey Sutton to his
group on Facebook agasa T and this
report is short and sweet the report
says that a spider-man 2099 live-action
show has been discussed for Disney Plus
in other words this will be a Sony
Marvel Studios collaboration if it is
greenlit with Kevin Feige Manning the
controls and that is all that's been
discussed so far so keep in mind that
they're simply just discussing this
right now there's no guarantee that a
spider-man 2099 Disney Plus show will be
made however there is a great president
for the show to be made as it follows
what Disney is currently trying to do
and will fit with what the MCU was
moving forward with very well for
starters if this is indeed happening and
Marvel Studios is considering making a
spider-man Disney Plus show that means
of course they're going to have to
cooperate with Sony and this is a great
sign that Marvel and Sony are playing
well with each other something that
people have been very worried about
since the whole spider-man in the MCU
scare that we had last summer but the
fact that Marvel and Sony are talking
with each other that mean
that spider-man should be in the MCU for
a pretty long time in fact there have
been reports of other Marvel and Sony
related projects coming to Disney Plus
Gina price of bite wood who was
previously signed on to direct Sony
silver and black film featuring silver
sable and black cat before it was
scrapped recently revealed that Disney
Plus was an option for them for the
project in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter when talking about
the scrapped project she said now
there's a thought of hey maybe we put it
on Disney Plus as a limited series but I
loved it more as a film with the two of
them so my hope is that one day it can
still happen
so here we have somebody who was set to
direct a Sony and Marvel Studios project
that was together saying that it was a
possibility that they could have taken
their project and turned it into a
Disney Plus show so that's great news
because that means that Sony and Marvel
are playing well with each other very
very well which again is great news for
spider-man sticking around at the MCU
and spider-man 2099 story would actually
kind of fit with the direction that
Marvel is heading now the spider-man of
2099 year 2099 is Miguel O'Hara and he's
from both Irish and Mexican descent and
as some of you may know Marvel is trying
to be pretty diverse right now with
adding characters to the MCU who are of
different ethnicities so spider-man 2099
is right along there ally
so in spider-man 2099 Miguel O'Hara
worked for the alchemax Corporation and
was tasked with imprinting genetic codes
into human physiology but after seeing
many of his test subjects turned into
monsters he tried to quit however his
boss used an hallucinogenic drug called
rapture that Bond's the user to its DNA
and got him hooked on it
he then told him that he'd have to
continue to work for the corporation for
him to get his fix as they were the only
company who made that drug so in order
to get rid of his addiction to the drug
he used the previous genetic experiment
on himself however the experiment was
sabotaged and what ended up happening
was that O'Hara's DNA was spliced with a
spider and he subsequently gained a
number of superpowers and removed his
addiction to the drug his old boss Tyler
stone finds out about his new
superpowers and sends agents to hunt him
down so in order to conceal his identity
while he fights all of these agents
Miguel dons a body suit with a mast
he once wore for the Mexican Day of the
Dead festival and that's where his
spider-man outfit comes from he
eventually goes on and decides to
embrace the character and dons himself
the new spider-man but here's where his
story could fit in the MCU with the
current way they're going
Miguel finds out that a scientist named
Jordan Boone at his old company alchemax
is conducting what they call virtual
unreality experiments to create a
doorway into another dimension now
eventually this would go on to become
successful and even at one point in time
Peter Parker from the past ends up
switching places with Miguel from 2099
and this is something that could
definitely come into play if you
consider that the multiverse is now
going to be a huge part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
since the multiverse is now a part of
the MCU really anything that you could
possibly think of is probably possible
so having a timeline that is set in 2099
and having 2099 spider-man would be very
doable for a Disney Plus series because
of the multiverse but let me know what
you all think about this would you like
to have a spider-man 2099 Disney Plus
show and would you like to have a
daredevil show with Charlie Cox
returning as Matt Murdock let me know
what you think about this new report of
these two new Marvel shows that could be
coming don't forget to comment below and
like this video and subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up today
and all things relating to Marvel and
the MCU for live updates you can follow
me on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you